це Європа У фокусі з вами Лара бабалола
Ласкаво просимо жахливі події на
Близькому Сході тримають світ у напрузі
після безпрецедентних терористичних атак
хамасу в
Ізраїлі ізраїльські війська потужно
бомбардують об'єкти хамас у секторі Газа
багато жителів намагаються втекти звідти
на південь Ізраїль звинувачує хамас у
тому що ті блокують виїзд цивільного
населення Вважається що в заручниках у
газі перебуває близько 200 осіб які
викрали під час терористичних атак в
Ізраїлі наслідки цього конфлікту
відчуваються і в Європі особливо серед
ізраїльтян І палестинців які там
проживають після терактів у столиці
Німеччини Берліні пройшли мітинги на
знак солідарності з Ізраїлем були і
демонстрації на підтримку
палестинців але інші як наприклад
футбольний клуб у Берліні використовують
спорт щоб зробити послання проти
ненависті і
насильства
гра єврейського футбольного клубу тус
маккабі у Берліні проходить у складних
обставинах поліцейські стоять на
сторожжі через побоювання антисемтських
нападів понад 50 років тому цей клуб
заснував чоловік який пережив голокост
але відтоді як хамас здійснив теракти в
Ізраїлі для нього настали важкі
часи на цьому рівні футболу це єдина гра
де навколо стільки
поліції Зараз ми спостерігаємо ситуацію
коли євреї ховають єврейську символіку
тому що бояться її показувати і виходити
на
вулиці того ж дня понад тися
палестинських демонстрантів зібралися на
мітинг у Берліні незважаючи на заборону
поліції останніми днями ми стали
свідками безлічі антисемтських
висловлювань і
дій ця ізраїльтянка в шоці ми будемо
Називати її інбал Вона живе у Німеччині
і згадує як вперше почула про напади
хамасу Моя сестра почала отримувати
повідомлення про людей яких вона знає І
які були там почала впізнавати людей на
відео а потім мама сказала нам що наш
двоюрідний брат також зник
безвісти тоді ми почали розуміти що
проблема трохи більша ніж ми
очікували відтоді інбал не отримувала
жодних новин про долю свого двоюрідного
брата вона пояснює як жахливо не знати
чи він та інші ще
живі Сьогодні я намагаюсь зосередитись
створити якусь рутину і пам'ятати що в
цьому світі є і
добро на жаль мені здається що це тільки
початок цього хаосу і
війни на стадіоні тус маккабі вшановують
пам'ять загиблих хвилиною мовчання перед
початком матчу
спочатку гру було скасовано через
побоювання за безпеку
гравців але зараз вони все ж таки вийшли
на поле у команді також є мусульмани і
християни які хочуть зробити спільне
послання А ми намагаємося бути чимось
більшим ніж спорт показати світу і
суспільству як це може працювати як ми
можемо жити разом і грати разом як
звичайні люди і немає значення Звідки ми
приїхали і навіть такий день Як цей
показує що все може бути краще ніж зараз
на вулиці
мусульманські мешканці також прийшли на
гру тус маккабі не всі згодні з реакцією
Ізраїлю на
терор у газі є невинні жінки і діти вони
нічого не
зробили але їх бомбардують днями і
ночами матч закінчився без
інцидентів невелика позитивна нота для
Берліна але багато хто тут побоюється Що
найгірші дні для Ізраїлю та гази ще
попереду одразу після зустрічі з інбал
ми отримуємо від неї жахливі новини її
двоюрідний брат
мертвий війна що триває в Україні
продовжує виривати людей з їхніх домівок
окрім українських біженців сотні тисяч
росіян багато з яких виступають проти
війни Кремля В Україні також покинули
свою країну як Поліна та її батьки Зараз
вона живе на Кіпрі з мамою татом і
Поліна ходить до школи в портовому місті
Лімасол місті гостинному до росіян і
починає почуватися там як удома У її
школі майже 80% учнів російськомовні і
надходить Усе більше заявок щодо
зрахування нових
учнів вчителька Поліни намагається
заспокоїти свій новий
клас діти радіють поверненню до
острівної приватної школи в Лімасолі
після каніку девятирічна Поліна ходить
до школи вже майже рік відколи її сім'я
переїхала на Кіпр з Москви вони
переїхали через кілька місяців після
вторгнення Росії в
Україну після канікул тут багато нових
облич більшість дітей з Росії та України
і Поліна почувається
розгубленою із самого початку ніби
взагалі нічого не відчувала але коли
під'їжджали то вже Було відчуття я
взагалі не мі с і так далі інший клас
трохи інші
люди нових дітей так багато що заняття
проходять у тимчасових контейнерах за
даними ЄС з початку війни на Кіпр
приїхало понад 13 000 українців і 38 000
росіян засновник школи Александр
шкуратов який наполовину росіянин
наполовину українець був буквально
завалений заявками на вступ до
школи коли батьки подають заявки ми
проводимо так звані ціннісні інтерв'ю
можуть бути батьки з доволі агресивними
поглядами вони або за війну або проти
війни на боці однієї країни на боці
іншої Ми залишаємо за собою право не
зараховувати такі сім'ї до школи тому що
вважаємо що це може бути джерелом
напруженості і дестабілізувати наш
колектив Здається цей підхід працює на
шкільному майданчику в Лімасолі всі діти
граються разом 80% уч тут походять з
Росії Білорусі та України але війна
здається дуже далекою тут звучить майже
виключно російська мова незважаючи на те
що це міжнародна приватна школа заняття
проводяться
англійською Ну мені на уроках
подобається говорити англійською але на
перервах мені більше подобається
говорити російською тому що в мене
більшість друзів поганенько знають
англійську тому так легше зазвичай
спілкуємося російською усі учні між
собоюрять Російською Тому що тут мало
хто не знає російської якщо хтось
говорить тільки англійською це одразу
можна зрозуміти і з ними говорять
англійською діти яки розмовляють
російською знають
англійську але не всі з них можуть
вільно говорити
англійською після школи Поліна пережовує
день у машині її батько Макс забрав її
зі старшою сестрою
маєю наступна зупинка центр лімасола
приблизно на тиждень сестри можуть
вибрати щось солодке в одному з
російських магазинів у місті гостинець
із
дому ми намагаємось знайти якісь такі
продукти які от ну дуже важливі без яких
ви Ну просто Плачете за кордоном і вони
для вас це смак батьківщини смак
дитинства рік тому у вересні оголошення
про мобілізацію в Росії змусило батька
Поліни Макса виїхати разом із сім'єю
менеджер фонду прямих не хоче щоб ми
називали його прізвище аби захистити
його родичів які залишилися вдома його
мати українка залишатися в Росії Яка
стає дедалі більш репресивною для нього
було
неможливим мабуть Важко пояснити дітям
Чому вони не можуть наприклад говорити з
бабусею
українською чи Чому вони не можуть
говорити про це їхня сім'я почувається
комфортно у Лімасолі це місто завжди
було популярним серед росіян іноді
називають Москвою на
середземномор'ї у 1990-х Кіпр став
податковим раєм для олігархів зараз тут
процвітає it-індустрія після початку
війни цілі компанії переїхали сюди з
Росії частково через те що росіянам тут
легше отримати візу ніж у багатьох інших
країнах
ЄС на кипрі завжди жили українці на
кипрі жили росіяни і Лімасол не
змінився ціни дійсно дуже високі
особливо в Лімасолі де живуть
росіяни досить важко знайти нормальне
житло тому що ціни
високі більшість людей живуть із
батьками мама Поліни Катя народилася в
Москві у російській столиці сім'я
планувала приїхати до умріяної квартири
зі свіжим ремонтом але війна зруйнувала
всі їхні плани в
Росії було складно залишитись без дому і
це важко це емоційно складно коли у тебе
немає
куріння тому що ми все продали В Москві
нас Кіпр дуже класно прийняв І це чудово
що є таке місце але ми все одно поки що
тут не
вдома у нинішніх реаліях я от собі прямо
зараз не можу уявити причину з якої ми
повернулися
б якщо от уявити я там найбільший страх
- це звикнути до такої реальності то що
насилля це нормально Що можна вбивати І
що не можна говорити про те що ти думаєш
що тобі потрібно вчити дітей не говорити
за межами твоєї домівки чи за межами
твоєї
кухні мистецтво улюблений предмет Поліни
в школі нерівні з фізкультурою вона каже
що не дуже сумує за своєю школою в
Москві але сумує за одним зі своїх
друзів і вона хотіла б знати що чекає на
її сім'ю
далімі ку ми сюди переїхали потім звідси
кудись іще
переїдемо ніби це якась пересадка в
літаку і поки що навіть невідомий
кінцевий напрямок цього
літака ну для мене це незрозуміло поки
що Поліна вже знайшла нових друзів і з
нетерпінням чекає на перехід до
четвертого класу її сім'я планує поки що
залишитись на Кіпрі принаймні до кінця
навчального
року краса Балтійського моря Воно відоме
свої незайманими пляжами і спокійним
мілководдям але зовнішність може бути
оманливою унікальна екосистема
Балтійського моря знаходиться під
загрозою занадто багато поживних речовин
змивається в море у формі нітратів
результат різке скорочення чисельності
морських мешканців на мальовничому
фйорді вайле в Данії Балтійське море
потребує реанімації ласе мікельсен з
Данії обожнює життя на воді але коли цей
рибалка-ветеран виводить свій човен у
море Він знає що шанси на вели у
[музика]
ма Балтійське море з його приголомшливою
природою одне з найпопулярніших
туристичних напрямків Північної Європи а
узбережжя вздовж фйорду вайле один з
найдорожчих житлових районів Данії проте
його зовнішня краса оманлива рибалка лас
мікельсен під час своїх щотижневих
виходів на риболовлю продовжує
спостерігати як фійорд повільно
вмирає під поверхнею води розростаються
водорості які каламутять воду і
позбавляють рибу та підводних рослин
життєво важливих світла і кисню кадри
зняті вченими показують як дно фіорду
стало майже безжиттєвим А колись у цих
водах водилося багато тріски камбали та
пінагору колись це було справжнім раєм
для рибалок каже мікельсен але тепер
риби майже не
залишилося він ходить у вже понад
півстоліття
мікельсон сподівався продовжити рибалити
після виходу на пенсію щоб мати
додатковий дохід тепер Виходити у море
вже немає
сенсу мене злить розчаровує те що ніхто
нічого не
робить здається що ті хто мав би діяти
лише намагається перекласти провину на
інших
на думку мікельсона в усьому винні
данські фермери у цій маленькій країні з
населенням трохи менше 6 мільйонів
жителів утримується вдвічі більше корів
і
свиней і багато фермерів використовують
на своїх полях добрива які зрештою
потрапляють у
море Ферма Крістіана арілда метсна
знаходиться всього в кількох кілометрах
від фйорду він каже що вже скоротив
використання нітратів до
мінімуму він використовує супутникові
знімки щоб відстежувати які поля
потребують добрив А які можуть обійтися
без них Але чоловік вважає що повністю
відмовитися від добрив
неможливо Я гадаю що це добре що ми
зменшили кількість азоту але я не думаю
що ми можемо піти далі Я гадаю що ми
знаходимося на найнижчій межі прийнятній
для нас
фермерів рослинам потріб поживні
речовини без них зерно Не виросте каже
фермер а оскільки він зменшив
використання добрив його рослини
виживають лише за рахунок того що
залишилося у землі
метц фєльце крістенсен знає про цю
проблему як менеджер з охорони природи
він керує проєктом спрямованим на
відновлення екосистеми у фйорді вайле
він знає жорсткі факти і
цифри на цей момент Ми Точно знаємо що
80% поживних речовин які потрапляють у
фіорд вайлі надходять від сільського
господарства Також ми маємо 10% від
міських стічних вод і можливо 10% від
рибного господарства але ситуація Ось
така і це нагадує нам про те на що
потрібно звернути
увагу стік нітратів регулярно спричиняє
бурухливий ріст
водоростей вони вкривають все у фйорді
знищуючи Навіть камку через нестачу
світла
ця шкамка один із найважливіших
елементів екосистеми вздовж узбережжя
Балтійського моря Вона виробляє кисень і
забезпечує середовище проживання для
дрібної риби саме тому крістенсен і його
команда із муніципалітету взялися за
висаджування нових галявин камки у
фйорді вайле але цей проєкт із
відновлення складний створюються також
штучні рифи та ферми із розведення мідій
ці блакитні мідії фільтрують брудну воду
що у свою чергу дозволяє більшій
кількості світла проникати глибше камка
може знову рости і відповідно виробляти
кисень але коли в море знову потрапляє
занадто багато поживних речовин що
спричиняє появу водоростей цей тонкий
баланс порушується і занепокоєння
природоохоронців не обмежується фйордом
вайла ми досягли цієї точки
розриву система руйнувалася останні 5-ш
років і це лише початок
ми спостерігати таку ситуацію по всій
Балтії уздовж узбережжя екосистема цього
внутрішнього моря була порушена
лас мікельсоен бачить лише крабів у
сітках які він розставляє у фйорді
вайле Оскільки у них більше немає
природних ворогів вони стали чумою яка
знищує водорості поїдає мідії та вбиває
мальків
риби
мікельсен сподівається що кожен у
регіоні візьме на себе більше
відповідальності і діятиме щоб врятувати
його фйорд адже проблема яку зараз
намагається вирішити Данія вже загрожує
всьому узбережжю Балтійського
моря ця рослина відома своїми цілющими
властивостями рослина Залізняка росте на
грецькому острові Крит кажуть що її
чайне листя допомагає від застуди та
покращує травлення це робить Залізняк
гарячим товаром і благословенням для
козівника йоргоса
копасакіса збіри продаж Чайного листя -
це величезна фінансова підмога для
копасакіса Саме тому він переїжджає зі
свого села туди де ці рослини ростуть
влітку високо на схилах левкаурі в горах
Криту це важкий шлях через безплідний
ландшафт але наприкінці подорожі на
нього чекає горщик із
золотом
рано вранці вим'я наповнені
повінця овець треба швидко подоїти бо
зараз сезон збору чаю
йоргоскопасакі спастуг у селі аннополіс
на південному заході Криту але кілька
днів на рік Він збирає
чай ми збираємо чай коли рослини
квітнуть і в них повно
нектару потім гаряче сонце їх
висушує
малотіра рослина більш відома як
Залізняк росте на висоті понад 1900 м у
горах
левкаорі багато людей тут запевняють що
вона має цілющі властивості на
автомобілі можна проїхати лише половину
шляху далі доводиться пересідати на
віслюка якого привезли до цієї частини
гори у кузові
пікапа у цих мішках повно хліба олії
картоплі та цибулі дляших
Ми також беремо їжу для тварин тому що
там її
недостатньо раніше вони проводили в
горах місяці виготовляючи сир тепер
проводять там лише ри тижні і чай
приносить набагато більше
прибутку життя тут
важке з дитиною я б не
витримав дружина пішла б від
мене
йоргос мул і два віслюки ри години
піднімаються вгору по кам'яністій землі
під палючим
сонцем інші вже працюють і
чекають перший гірський чай можливо
внаслідок кліматичних змін щороку
Залізняк росте на все більшій висоті над
рівнем моря
[музика]
настає ніч помічник приносить зібраний
за день урожай при світлі місяця йоргос
розкладає зібрані рослини на брезент на
землі після збору врожаю Залізняк не
може залишатися на сонці або в
мішках він від Сирії і
зіпсується наступного ранку йоргос і
його двоюрідний брат уже наполегливо
працюють вони власники цих пасовищ але
їм всее одно потрібно отримати дозвіл
від лісництва на заготівлю Залізняка ті
рослини знаходяться під охороною і
збирати їх можна лише в обмеженій
кількості ми маємо бути обережними щоб
не виривати їх з корінням інакше ми
вб'ємо
рослини залізняку потрібні роки щоб
відрости
назад
Залізняк тут ріс завжди але ніколи не
було комерційного ринку для
нього зараз ми заробляємо на ньому
непогані гроші але це все одно важка
праця цей крицький чай користується
великим попитом навіть в
Афінах ми завжди знали що Залізняк
корисний ми завжди пили його коли в нас
була засту лихоманка він справді
допомагає їхні дідусі та бабусі також
збирали врожай Тут у горах а ще будували
кам'яні будиночки щоб мати хоч трохи
затишку та укриття від
стихії трав'яний чай готують на свіжій
воді із місцевого джерела
це дикий білий чебрець він надає чаю
чудового
аромату коли вода закипа ми знімаємо чай
з вогню і даємо йому настоятися протягом
хвилин чай дає їм приємний заряд
бадьорості перед зворотною
дорогою ми завантажили на мула сім
мішків Кожен з яких важить 6
кгра разом це приблизно 42 кг
мул може нести до
120 проблема не стільки у вазі скільки в
об'ємі дорого скаже що це важка робота а
також важко знайти помічників щоб
зібрати
врожай двічі на тиждень вони перевозять
чай із Залізняка до свого села де на
нього вже чекають
покупці мережа супермаркетів в ефінах
купує весь їхній
[музика]
урожай багато поколінь крицян
покладалися на цілющі властивості свого
гірського чаю який черпав свою силу у
цьому кам'янистому безплідному
ландшафті що робити на одному із
найменших островів на заході Шотландії
відповідь може вас здивувати Цей острів
славиться своїм камінням круглим пласким
і красивої форми тож ці камінці ідеально
підходять для запускання жабок або
скімінгу як там називають це заняття і
для багатьох людей це дещо набагато
більше ніж хобі Ласкаво просимо на ідейл
це містечко має крихідне населення але
воно стало міжнародною гарячою точкою
для змагань зі
скімінгу до перемоги буквально
камінчиком докинути А на сьогодні це все
дякуємо що були з нами і не забувайте ви
можете зайти на наш сайт або в соціальні
мережі щоб дізнатись більше історій з
усієї Європи Дякуємо за перегляд і до
зустрічі
[музика]